[Music]
welcome back so in the next couple of
lectures I'm gonna show you how to use
the Fourier transform the fast Fourier
transform to compress images okay so
this is one of the coolest and most
useful applications of the FFT in our
modern world is using the FFT for
compression in general you can use it
for audio compression for image
compression when you stream TV or movies
or YouTube you're using some kind of a
Fourier transform based compression
algorithm okay and I'm gonna start with
compression based on the fast Fourier
transform and then I'm going to
eventually move on to the wavelet
transform which is kind of an enhanced
Fourier transform that's better for
compressing natural signals like audio
and images okay but before I do I need
to point out this is not just the
standard FFT in Python or MATLAB this is
actually the FFT - it's a two
dimensional FFT if we're going to be
doing compression on two-dimensional
images so I'm going to walk you through
kind of how you can think about this
this two dimensional FFT okay so let's
say you have some some picture I'm gonna
say I don't know if this is a picture of
my dog Mort
that's Mort that looks like a pig okay
fine that's a pig and we're going to
Fourier transform this pig so the first
thing is just how do you compute a
two-dimensional FFT then I'll show you
how to use that for compression okay so
the first thing is the FFT to command
FFT - and essentially what you do in an
FFT - this is super simple you just FFT
every row and then you FFT every column
or vice versa it doesn't really matter
so the first step is we're going to FFT
every single row okay so this is just
FFT on rows and we're gonna get some new
image and I can't draw this image
because it's in some weird Fourier
transform and space that's going to look
it's gonna look messy some some weird
messy Fourier
okay and then once I Fourier transform
all the rows I'm gonna Fourier transform
all of the columns of that new image and
now I'm going to FFT all of the columns
okay so we're gonna FFT columns and that
is going to be how we FFT to an image so
this is the FFT of an image and I'm
gonna draw it kind of like this because
that's how I think of it there's usually
you're gonna see when you FFT an image
there's gonna be this kind of plus sign
and then some stuff and everywhere else
and I'll explain that later okay but the
basic idea is if you want to compute the
FFT to the FFT of a two-dimensional
image you FFT all the rows then you FFT
all of the columns and you get this this
representation and the way you can think
about this simply is just like if I FFT
--d a one dimensional signal like an
audio signal I'm representing that as a
sum of sines and cosines in that
one-dimensional variable here I'm
representing this picture of this pig as
a sum of a bunch of sines and cosines in
X&Y so you can think of each fourier
coefficient here every single fourier
coefficient here corresponds to a
particular spatial wave number this
corresponds to some you know cosine KX x
sine
I don't know J Y where this is the K and
J coordinate of this thing and if you
think about it I always imagine for
people holding a bedsheet and kind of
forcing it you know in one direction at
a frequency of K and forcing it in the
other direction at a frequency of J and
it would create this kind of standing
wave I guess this doesn't have to be
cosine sine this could be cosine cosine
or each of these has a phase this could
be cosine KX times cosine KY or sine KX
times sine J Y or whatever it doesn't
matter
cosines and sines but the basic idea is
that you know every single point in this
two dimensional Fourier transform has an
X frequency and a Y frequency and that's
giving you this kind of standing wave
bedsheet
structure and you're gonna add all of
those up to get kind of the pixel
intensities of this original signal and
I'm gonna talk a lot more about this
we're gonna I'm gonna work through some
examples we're gonna see this working in
MATLAB and in Python okay but the basic
idea is before you transform all the
rows all the columns and then you get
this two-dimensional FFT in python and
matlab it's kind of a built-in command
to do this fun exercise for you at home
would be to convince yourself that it
doesn't matter what order you do this
operation you could do the fft on
columns first and then do the fft on the
rows or vice versa and you're going to
get the exact same two dimensional
fourier transform so I think you should
convince yourself of that okay good
but now I want to show you how you would
use this for compression this is this is
really cool I'm going to show you kind
of mathematically how you use this for
compression and then we're gonna code
this up in the next few lectures in
Python and in MATLAB so the basic idea
is that when you have your image this is
in image space and maybe this is a
megapixel image so it's got one million
pieces of information maybe this time
I'll draw a cat okay that's a cat
happier than most cats I've seen okay so
what we're gonna do let's say that this
is kind of one megapixel image of a cat
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to Fourier transform this
thing that's a curly F FFT we're going
to FFT to this image and we're gonna get
again a million kind of Fourier
coefficients so now in Fourier we still
have a million Fourier coefficients and
I'm always gonna draw it like something
like this it's not exactly what it looks
like but the basic idea is that you have
a lot of Fourier coefficients but we
have observed and this doesn't have to
be true this is not obvious why this is
true this just happens to be true
is that all almost all natural images
things that you would see like and not
not just in that natural
like a mountain or a stream or a field
but like this pen or what you see right
here this this lightboard studio or a
picture of a coffee cup or a cat images
that you would see with your eyes
generally when you Fourier transform
them most of the Fourier coefficients
are really really small this doesn't
have to be true but this is true ok so
most of these Fourier coefficients are
very very very small negligibly small
and you can truncate them and throw them
away so all of these Fourier
coefficients these million Fourier
coefficients maybe only 10,000 of them
are large and so I can zero out 99% of
those Fourier coefficients I can
threshold them out manually make them
exactly equal to zero
ok so that's what we're gonna do is
we're gonna threshold and what I mean is
we're only going to maybe keep 1% of the
largest largest fourier coefficients so
now and it's a little hard to draw this
but usually what that means is now it's
like only just the very very largest
ones Fourier coefficients and this
original image we're gonna keep like 1%
or 2% or something like that and the the
magic is that if you throw away really
really small fourier coefficients your
threshold n'ver story a transform this
is the eye FFT to when you inverse
Fourier transform there is very little
loss in your original image ok so this
is I don't know if you remember
parseval's theorem but parseval's
theorem says that there's kind of a
relationship between the energy and
fourier space and the energy in signal
in pixel space and so if I'm only
throwing away I'm throwing away a lot of
these Fourier coefficients 99% of the
Fourier coefficients but the ones I'm
throwing away are so small that they
don't actually change the norm or the
energy of this of this this signal very
much because I'm only throwing away the
ones that are almost zero anyway and so
Parcells theorem tells me is that if I
only threshold the very very
small Fourier coefficients it has
negligible degradation of my original
image okay and this is the basis of all
image compression is the N audio
compression is this idea that when you
Fourier transform your signal your audio
or image signal
most of those Fourier transform
coefficients are very very small
negligibly small and because the
Parcells theorem if I zero out those
small Fourier coefficients and I only
keep the largest ones which oftentimes
is only 1% or 2% of these Fourier
coefficients if I only keep those then
when I inverse for you transform the
image looks almost identical to the
original full resolution image ok now
you might be asking why is this actually
give you a compression well when I take
a megapixel image actually on my phone I
think it's like 8 or 12 megapixels now I
am storing a million pieces of
information a million pixels of
information and if I Fourier transformed
there are still a million pieces of
information here but when I threshold
and I only keep one percent of these
Fourier coefficients here this is where
the compression comes in so when you
save a JPEG image on your phone or on
your computer you're not saving the
million pixels
you are saving only the one or two
percent largest Fourier coefficients
this is JPEG okay and so on your hard
drive you don't have a million pieces of
information you only maybe have 10 or
20,000 pieces of information
corresponding to the largest Fourier
coefficients and essentially the IJ or
the JK locations of where those Fourier
coefficients are so this is basically a
list of you know K comma J comma F hat K
comma J comma F hat this is just a big
list on your hard drive of only the 1%
or 2% largest Fourier coefficients that
you need to keep okay and that's
actually why the fast part of the fast
Fourier transform is so important is
that if you had to do an order N squared
expensive Fourier transform and
inverse Fourier transform this would be
too expensive to decompress your image
so when you have a JPEG on your on your
phone and and you you click on it or you
open it it immediately almost
instantaneously decodes it into pixel
space so that you can see it but it's
going very very flexibly from this
sparse compressed representation to this
full megapixel representation because it
can compute this Fourier transform very
rapidly ok so if it wasn't for the fast
Fourier transform even though we could
still compress images it would take
forever to compress them and it would
take forever to decompress them so so
the F the first F and the FFT is why we
can do this this image compression so
ubiquitously ok so just to summarize you
can take the Fourier transform of two
dimensional images just Fourier
transform all rows and then all columns
and then what we find is that when we
Fourier transform natural images that
you see in nature things that you would
see with your eyes generally they are
very very sparse in Fourier space so you
can get away with truncating or throwing
away most of those small Fourier
coefficients and by only keeping maybe
the top one or two percent of these
Fourier modes you get a massive
compression you have to store less on
your harddrive you have to transfer less
when you text some on a picture and
because of the fast Fourier transform
you can invert or decompress that
representation very efficiently into the
original image ok so in the next couple
of lectures we're going to code this up
in Python and in MATLAB and we're going
to kind of get a little bit better
feeling for you know why this is
compressible how it's compressible and
what different features why some images
are more compressible than others and so
that's all coming up thank you